this tournament has both rapid and Bliss
time formats which format do you prefer
and which one do you think plays more
into your strengths
yeah I like Blitz the most indefinitely
um but maybe I'm better than rapid I
mean it's difficult to say actually but
I remember when I consider rapid to be
my least favorite uh you know time
control but I was like the most
successful in it in the past I mean I
was like European champion and so on
yeah but basically anything about
classical you know it's very pain it's
just fun you know to play and not
looking back I think like most of the
chess players they love playing Blitz
the most but for some people you know
they love it but they are not as good as
they help they are I don't know I think
I used to because I focused on the
classical chess much more in the past I
used to be my specialty much more so
because I play so much more Accent on
the preparation and less on let's say
skills in the time scrambles and all
that
I think there were more rapid implicit
events recently so maybe I'll get a
little bit a little bit more around it
but I'm still not a specialist in Rapid
and Blitz but you know I'm having a lot
of fun playing rapidly so and especially
play so much online over the board is
different because things are moving
quickly it gets a little physical
sometimes so yeah I'm looking I'm
looking forward I always would prefer a
longer format uh so I prefer classical
and then rapid and then Blitz just
because
uh chess is about strategy and then
there's a lot more time to think in rap
it's like I used to do very well in
Rapid maybe some time back like I wanted
2018 but uh we'll see what happens
I don't know it's very hard to say like
when I was younger I used to love 25
plus 10 as if you know why it was kind
of perpetuous but still super slow but
now I'm kind of old and unpatient and
you know I can't calculate anyway so and
all the video events are with um Mr 15
Boston so it's kind of strange for me to
play any of these time controls actually
but like I think that's five plus two
bleach is very tricky I mean since we
are playing three plus two and three
plus two is just just way quicker so
yeah like last year I got completely
smashed in fortnite so obviously it must
be a 25 which I prefer yeah I don't know
which one I will prefer but I think here
um Blitz might be easier for me because
as I said I'm the last rated then in
Blitz you can expect something more uh
dramatic
so I think it will be more uh random so
it can help me
or to play The Blitz but my friends tell
me that I'm I'm a better corrupted
player so I I generally love playing
Short Time Performance because
there's not much preparation and it's
more about coming up with surprising
ideas
um that's a that's a good good question
because I used to play Blitz a lot
not not online but it's over the boards
when in Ukraine there was a lot of
tournaments about it I think I played
less Rapids but it's hard to demand what
is my favorite time control because I
think Gucci's player tops player has to
be good in every type
I mean I've learned to like
do I put more than I used to but in
general I think it's
kind of the ultimate format for the
audience for the players you can just
play a bunch of those don't not get
tired like he can play casually and you
can play it in more serious and
competitive fashion like we're doing
here and
in general I have this ability to play
fast and put a lot of pressure on the
clock my opponents of course in less
time
there is to play the the best I am
I've generally done pretty well in in
Rapid in in the grand chess tour
in terms of what I like I probably like
to prefer Blitz but I like both
[Music]